here's a story that we're not supposed
to talk about but whatever let's talk
about it let's see
your move social media platforms you can
kick me off if you want but i'm just
going to read the news here
there was a recount there was there was
a
an audit of the recount in arizona okay
and the audit established that there
were no substantial differences between
the hand count of the ballots and the
official canvas results for the county
in the 2020 election
that's the headline that you are going
to see in the news the audit found that
there were no substantial differences
between the hand count of ballots and
the official count for the county that
that resulted in the 2020 election
okay biden won arizona
by 10
457 votes
okay
what happens beyond the headline the
audit established the hand recount what
happens beyond the headline there were
numerous findings of problems with the
election and evidence indicating that
tens of thousands of ballots were
illegally cast or counted so some of
those ballots should not have been cast
in the first place and some of the
ballots even if they were cast by real
people who were eligible voters should
not have been counted because they did
not follow the rules for casting the
ballots
the review revealed that more than 17
000
uh return envelopes were duplicates
maricopa county recorded more than 6545
early voting return envelopes then this
reviewing organization determined
existed
and 15 035 mail-in votes in maricopa
county were from voters who had moved
prior to the registration deadline
another
6591 mail in ballots came from voters
who had moved out of arizona prior to
the registration deadline and 1 718 mail
in votes came from voters who moved
within arizona but out of maricopa
county
prior to the registration deadline a
good reporting on this is in the
federalist right now
so what does this mean which which
headline is to be believed did biden win
arizona or did
did biden maybe not win arizona well yes
it is true that the audit found that the
there was no substantial difference
between the hand count of the ballots
and the numbers we were told shortly
after the election
but that's not really the question the
question is how many of those ballots
were eligible to be cast or counted in
the first place
there just this number 17 000 duplicate
images
biden didn't even win the state by 11
000 votes
that seems pretty suspect to me all
those other numbers as well
the media are only the establishment
media are only going to give you that
statement the the wreak the hand recount
and the official numbers after the
election were basically the same okay
but that's not the point
the point is how many of those ballots
should have been counted in the first
place and these reviews
suggest to me
that the answer is far from clear
and if it is clear it's maybe clear in a
different direction
i think that this
recount is a vindication of the people
who say that there was a lot of
corruption and there are other numbers
too i'm just giving you the top-line
views there's a lot of other shady stuff
that was discovered in this audit in
this review
i think the people who demanded the
audit and the review were obviously
justified in doing so
but one of the problems with these
mail-in ballots is that
there's very little you can do
it's very it's very difficult to trace
these things to compare these things
it's hard to count them in the first
place that's why we've been so reticent
as a country to use them but now that
democrats think that they can really
count on that advantage they're pushing
them very very hard i'm so glad that you
like that clip that makes me feel
really good you can leave me a comment
here on youtube you can subscribe on
youtube but the thing that i would love
most
is if you would go to apple podcast but
if i stitch your google play type in the
michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]